Aujourd'hui, c'est le 1er avril mais
pourquoi fait-on des blagues ce jour-là ?
Cette tradition remonterait
au milieu du XVIe siècle,
quand le début de l'année a été fixé au 1er janvier
à la place semble-t-il du 1er avril.
Certaines personnes, un peu longues à la détente,
auraient malgré tout, continuer
à s'offrir des présents à cette date.
Les convertis au nouveau calendrier, pour se moquer,
leur auraient alors offert des cadeaux un peu ridicules,
qui petit à petit se sont transformés
en farces et en blagues.
Et le poisson dans tout ça ?
Selon certaines sources, il serait lié à la
pêche aux maquereaux qui redémarre au printemps.
L'occasion autrefois d'offrir du poisson.
D'autres sources suggèrent qu'il est lié à l'interdiction de la pêche dans certaines régions.
On offrait alors de faux poissons aux pêcheurs.
Manifestement, toutes ces traditions
se sont mélangées dans la marmite du temps
pour donner une drôle de bouillabaisse
et une "capsule de déconfiné" qui fait la blague.
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné"
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...